[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to tonight's
episode of beginner breakdown my name is
always is Alex mullering and I'm excited
to be uh talking with you tonight the
theme is thinking calculation move
selection right you're playing the game
of chess the whole game is about what am
I supposed to do how do I think about my
move and making those right decisions
and so today I'm going to teach you
about thinking which we may think we
know but sometimes it it applies
differently in different situations
so I have good news for you when we're
playing a game of chess there's actually
only two times we have to think it's
really exciting I know you thought it
was a lot more than that it's actually
just two we only have to think
when it's our move
and when it's our opponent's move but if
we think when it's our move and our
opponents move then we're totally good
it's just those two times I'm being a
little facetious here but
um the real question is what should we
be thinking about in those two
situations because I think it is
slightly different how should we be
managing our time especially if you're
playing with a clock or even if you're
playing just with a friend casually you
still don't want to be the one sitting
there thinking forever we do have a
limited amount of processing power to
calculate our variations so let's
consider some positions and kind of walk
it through and out let me present you a
few different situations
so here's our first situation imagine
you're playing a classical game of chess
for those not familiar with tournament
terminology this basically means it's a
long-form game and we're going to say
both players have over an hour on the
clock so plenty of time to think
in this position you're playing with the
white pieces and you have already
decided to recapture the d-pawn I
believe Black's last move was to capture
here
so we will recapture this Pawn
now it is our opponent's turn
and instead of quickly playing a move
they put their hands on their head start
analyzing the position you know really
trying to get in deep and trying to
figure out what should I do here and
there are some candidate moves they
might play
but it's their move so we don't know
exactly what they're going to play
what should we be thinking about here
while it's their turn to move
any thoughts from our audience either
online or in person feel free to comment
what would you be thinking about here as
it's their turn to move
how can we use our time
uh Mickey K in the chat says potential
threats so that's a really good thing
and we can actually do this for both
sides we can think what are their
threats what are ours
maybe what moves are we threatening or
what positional ideas are we threatening
what are their ideas uh Teo just
suggests F6 so actually looking at
possible moves they might play
candidate moves checks and captures
Queen H4 so a lot of different ways
people are approaching this some people
it seems about half and half are
thinking uh one half is saying we should
think about what are the ideas what's
the kind of overall structure in the
position what are the threats and then
the other half are suggesting moves and
saying okay what if they play this or
what if they play this what are we going
to do in those situations how do we
think about the position
okay so already this is really really
helpful now let's imagine that they
spent several minutes and eventually
come up with the move Knight to B4
and maybe we were expecting a move like
Pawn to F6 or queen to B6
um but Knight to B4 was a little
surprising to us
now it's our move
what should we be thinking about here
has our process changed at all
what are you thinking about uh this is
still Fury so this is kind of like in
the French
um
I imagine it was like they played Knight
F6 quickly and we pushed some of the
advanced French and their night drops
back here and they've tried to break
through with C5 we've defended with C3
that's where these pawns have ended up
um so that's basically where we are but
I believe this is still theoretical
night before I'm not sure how
theoretical it is it's it's a bit more
unusual but I think it has seen play
even at the high levels
um okay so in the chat a few suggestions
someone's suggesting just playing a move
Bishop B1
someone is saying whether we should keep
our Bishop by moving it whether we
should move it to B5 to keep it in the
game or maybe we just think should we
even should we just allow this trait to
happen maybe if we just move our Knight
somewhere then our Queen will defend we
can consider stuff like that
um
we should consider the value of the
pieces without trading so different
thoughts again the same kind of ideas
some people are suggesting more abstract
how do we think about this position some
are suggesting let's look at a move and
go from there and I think both can be
helpful but I am going to give some
suggestions and guidance so don't worry
we'll be getting to that but I just want
you to start thinking about how you
think about these positions
let me give you another situation here
and actually in this position for those
uh looking for it I believe Bishop to B1
is the best move
um we don't really want to trade our
Bishop pair if we don't have to and even
though it looks a little silly all the
way on the Square notice that our Bishop
has a long range it's looking at a lot
of potentially important squares so it's
still fairly active from here
okay a new situation
now
looks quite similar we still have maybe
like a French type structure right you
see a lot of these same ideas we haven't
had an exchange of these pawns yet but
now imagine we're in a Blitz game
five minutes no delay no increment
nothing our opponent has about three
minutes and 50 seconds left on the clock
and plays this move
we have about four minutes left on the
clock and it's our turn
so we don't have not we don't have very
little time so what should we be
thinking about in this position how does
it change that it's a faster game
does that affect anything is it it's
should we think differently okay uh
people in chat long term strategy we
have suggestions of
um
Teo has seen the idea developing bishop
or castling so considering how do we get
these pieces into the game maybe we get
our King safe someone saying Bishop sack
for the fun of it and it is fun but it
actually is also the best move here so
in this type of position you really
don't have a lot of time to think
abstractly right when we're playing in a
Blitz game and we have some tactics like
we've noticed that we are not castled
and our opponent is and kind of all of
our pieces are starting to point in this
direction our Pawn chain is lined up in
this direction towards their Castle
you'll notice and whichever way your
pawns are facing like kind of the angle
sometimes you'll have a pawn chain going
this way sometimes this way that's
usually indicating the side of the board
you are wanting to be fighting on
because your pawns will have more
control in that direction
um so we want to fight on the queen side
and actually here if we look at our
checks and captures our forcing moves
right any move we talked about this last
week but a forcing move is any move that
forces our opponent
um to immediately respond to whatever
our threat is or suffer some serious
disadvantage sometimes they can't even
effectively avoid the disadvantage so in
this case one of those would be Bishop
takes H7
um but notice that when we're in this
type of position we can't just sacrifice
for the fun of it we do want to make
sure even though we don't have a lot of
time we would still want to calculate
and say does this work what would we do
uh depending on how they play
so Bishop takes H7
is I think a really good candidate move
here it looks like a reasonable position
to try and get away with it
if they take with their King what is our
follow-up
um move if they don't take with the king
the good news is we can at the very
least just drop the bishop back and
we'll be very safe and we have won a
pawn and their King is weaker so they
probably are obligated to take our
Bishop
what might we do in that position
Knight G5 very good uh Knight G5 check
and we're again putting black in a
really bad spot
if they move their King back
what would we follow up with there
Queen H5 and with our Knight Our Queen
together will be threatening Checkmate
and this is kind of a Greek gift
sacrifice the problem here for black
is it actually doesn't matter if they
move their King away or if they take our
Knight because either way
we have a Checkmate threatened
if they take we activate our rook and we
still threaten Checkmate they can't like
ever push the pawns to try and get out
of it because we can always push this
Pawn now and cover their escape
um if they move forward so we're not
going to go too much into the the Greek
gift Theory right now but if they move
forward there's a lot of good things you
can do queen to G4 looks very strong
um maybe threatening to
playing Knight takes E6 you can also
probably get away with H5 here and
sacrifice this Knight if they take I'm
sure there is some Checkmate somewhere
yeah this is mate
and you can spend time now in a Blitz
game you'll be able to calculate that so
you'll kind of have to go with your gut
but
we do think about it differently when
it's arm move versus when it's our
opponent's move and based on the time
controls so those are just two of the
ways that can impact how we actually are
managing our time and thinking uh okay
really quickly uh question why Castle so
castling is good sometimes in this
position we actually want our Rook to be
on the edge and part of the attack
usually I recommend castling before your
10th move of the game in some closed
positions like this one you notice how
these pawns are very locked up you can
delay castling slightly also notice how
there's really none of blacks pieces
attacking our King at all so we are
still really safe even though we haven't
castled but usually you're going to want
to Castle
okay let's uh yeah let's jump into
kind of breaking it Down based on the
turns
because I think this is really the
biggest difference
so when it's your turn and your
opponent's turn I do think there is a
helpful distinction in how we actually
start to think about these positions
in this position let's say that we are
looking at the board and our opponent
plays the move Knight to F3
there's a few steps I want to give you
for what your process should be or at
least what's been helpful for me take it
or leave it When approaching how do I
make the right move here
the first question is well the first
step is if you're playing in a game like
over the board or like for a tournament
you'll write down the move take note of
it if you're playing online it does this
automatically for you but either way you
do want to take a mental note okay what
did they just play what's the actual
move they played from there the real
first step is find the threats
what have they threatened by their move
and there could be multiple ones so
really quickly looking at this position
white just played the move Knight to F3
does anyone see
if white is making any threats with this
move
what threats might white be making here
that we need to look out for maybe there
are none
but maybe there are some
uh how so
of the night
oh wait
oh no no I missed no worries no worries
okay so a lot of people in the chat have
an idea
and they're actually correct so Knight
F3 is making a really big threat that if
it is actually threatening to trap Our
Queen
notice that our Queen is actually just
it's which is so crazy because this is
such a normal looking position but our
Queen is already pretty limited on which
squares she can go to
if you can't go forward or diagonal that
way the Knight controls the square and
the square the bishop controls the
square this bishop controls this Square
so right now the only she actually can't
move anywhere except for backwards
and we can actually use a piece with
this Knight to cut her off totally and
that is by playing Bishop to G5
if Bishop to G5 is played this queen is
actually just straight up trapped so
imagine we play some move like Bishop E7
here
Bishop to G5 and our Queen has no safe
squares
remarkable
okay so our first question is we want to
identify the threats sometimes you will
find a position where there are none and
in that case you can move on to the next
step
but in the case where there are threats
we want to Now find what moves what
candidate moves can we come up with that
would help us deal with the threat if
there weren't a threat we found we would
ask the same question what candidate
moves do we have we just would be
looking for any normal looking move not
necessarily how to get out of a problem
so a candidate move
um yeah so to summarize that so when
your opponent makes a move the first
thing you always want to do is ask are
there any threats that they've made from
this move and sometimes it is pretty
obvious like imagine instead of Knight
F3 they had played
D5 not a good move gives up a pawn it's
not defended but it does make a threat
it's threatening to take our Knight
that's a problem so we would need to
find some way to deal with it in this
case we could just take back
first question is are there any threats
um
and
the next thing is we want to find
candidate moves a candidate move is just
any move it's basically like the moves
you look at the position you're like
this is kind of what I would like to
play
um
and I like to save that step until after
we detect if there's threats against us
because it's going to save us time right
if we see this position and it looks
like a normal position and you don't see
this move this threat of Bishop to G5
then we're going to be spending maybe a
lot of time thinking okay maybe I'll
play Bishop to D6 or maybe bishop to E7
and castles maybe I'll play Bishop to D7
to Queen side castle like we're going to
waste a lot of time looking at moves
that are pretty irrelevant
um but once we detect the threat we're
actually ready to start analyzing our
candidate moves
okay uh yes so what candidate moves
would you consider here in this position
for black we don't want to lose our
Queen so early in the game so what might
we think about playing
uh okay we could Retreat the queen back
to her home Square
that's a good candidate move what else
a lot of people in chat suggesting just
Pawn to H6 controlling this square that
makes sense to me as well so so far we
have two candidate moves Queen to D
eight Pawn to H6
any other candidate moves we should
consider here
what would you play if you had black
here
E5 suggested that's interesting
Queen to E7 interesting
okay someone's suggesting a king move
I'm not so sure about King E4 oh that
was a typo looks like uh Knight D4 okay
so taking this Pawn
so we can come up with this list and
what I would say is for every move we
look at we want to say first of all did
it stop the threats right so if we play
if we look at a move like Knight takes
D4 the problem is does it stop the
threats
and that's actually this is a really
interesting one what do we think this
Knight takes D4 stop the threat of
Bishop to G5
yes or no
okay so why not what's the problem with
this move
doesn't necessarily eliminate any
threats to push his own self in trouble
with the knife
uh yeah so we are kind of making a
counterfeit against this Knight
and uh they're actually this is kind of
a subtle
subtlety of the position if white is not
careful we actually can get out of the
threat
so the question is does this effectively
deal with it or not and we're gonna have
to see your reasoning why because it is
a little trickier than it looks
foreign
so the chat is kind of jumping ahead and
you're correct in the chat
um
in a way this does prevent or sorry this
does not prevent the threat of Bishop G5
um well it doesn't it doesn't here's
what I mean this move absolutely makes
Bishop G5 a bad move
because if you play Bishop G5 now
what is Black's response to not lose the
queen
this is a bit of a tricky one but we
always want to think about our forcing
moves
so White's next move they would love to
take our Queen
but actually because of the way we've
put our Knight we can prevent that from
happening by attacking something more
important
E5 right here
I I think you might be onto something if
we can threaten this King then they
can't take our Queen right if you're in
check you got to get out of check so do
we have any moves we can play to
threaten the king yeah
um Knight to f
3 yes correct so this is actually called
an Intermezzo we're going to play Knight
takes F3 and this is check so there is
now no time to take our Queen
and whichever way white recaptures this
Knight right if they use their Pawn or
their Queen either way notice that now
that Knight is no longer there to defend
this bishop which means we can take the
bishop and our Queen is safe and
actually we're up a piece
the problem with this move is not that
it it does successfully prevent Bishop
to G5 but unfortunately it actually
loses to a different move
white now can instead play this really
tricky line Knight takes D4 and you
might think wait but I can just take
back with my queen
what is White's move here to just almost
win the game on the spot
again white has a really beautiful move
that will end up winning the queen
um
Bishop to
25 yes and just like
um when we played Knight takes F3 and
called check and you couldn't do
anything you had to stop the check
Bishop to B5 is a check
but it also attacks Our Queen
so we have to do something about the
check we can move our King we can block
with the bishop or with the queen but no
matter what we do white will always have
a way to take the queen
um so Knight takes D4 is a really
interesting idea it does prevent Bishop
G5 unfortunately it loses to something
else which means we're going to kind of
jump back and let me again do a quick
recap of our steps when it's our turn so
they played Knight F3 first step is are
there any threats right sometimes it'll
be by the piece itself right if Pawn to
D5 then that piece is making a direct
threat in this case it's the Knight is
now supporting another piece that piece
can make a threat on its next turn
and sometimes it's even something as
it's like a discovery right in the case
of this variation
white makes a threat
by a discovery right the piece that
moves is not the piece that makes a
threat now at this point it's too late
for us to do anything about it
um but in principle right there's lots
of ways a move can cause threats so the
first step and it might be some time
consuming right is you want to spend
some a lot of time calculating what are
the threats once you identified them we
want to look at our candidate moves
sometimes those will be preventative
well they're always going to be
preventative of the threats but they
might do it in different ways so like
Knight takes D4 the idea is we're not
actually stopping the Bishop from coming
to the square
we are just going to take the night if
they do and win material that way
a move suggested earlier like Queen to
d8
is also not preventing the Bishop from
coming to the square but it's giving us
more wiggle room with the queen to
escape or more potential blockers so
it's another way to solve the threat the
move suggested H6 it actually does
prevent the Bishop from coming to this
Square
but the the key here is we're first
going to again after we've figured out
the threats we're going to identify all
the candidate moves right all the moves
we think these are reasonable moves for
us to play in this position
you know in any kind of given middle
game position there's probably an
average of 30 to 40 legal moves if you
spend your time looking at every single
one of those moves you'll you'll be
playing one game of chess for the rest
of your life so being able to kind of
minimize down to what looks reasonable
and first say if they have a threat I
don't have a lot of like I can't just
push silly pawns I have to look at the
moves that actually deal with this
either by making a bigger threat or by
stopping your threat or by preparing
answers for it
um so we'll look at all of our candidate
moves identify what we have and then
we'll kind of go through one at a time
my recommendation is to start with the
move that you think just looks the best
right
um because if you start with other moves
if you start with one that looks the
worst or one that looks the simplest or
you know different things
you're probably going to be wasting your
time on variations you don't really need
to be looking at if you start with the
what looks like the best so let's say
here we said I think Queen d8 is the
best move for black
we can spend a good deal of time looking
at this move thinking what might they
play they still might go through with
this attack what are we going to do then
they might just Castle or do normal
development what are we going to do then
and we can kind of think about that and
if we're happy with those positions if
we think they're going to give us an
advantage or at least not put us at a
disadvantage then we might well go for
this if not then we'll continue and
we'll kind of have this as a baseline
right after we have looked at these
variations and kind of understand where
we stand then we can start to look at
some of the other options and say okay
if I play H6 am I going to be any better
than I was when I played Queen to d8
if so then I'm probably going to put
that one up the kind of ranking and once
I've looked at all of my moves I'll say
okay which one is at the top now which
one do I like the most
my advice is also don't re-analyze any
of these ideas right so if we spend some
time looking at Queen d8
you don't want to spend a lot of time
then kind of coming back and saying okay
what about H6 but wait let me re-look at
Queen d8 and let me go back and
try and really look at it just one time
and if you need to refresh yourself on
how you got to those positions you can
do that quickly
but you really don't want to reanalyze
unless like you are looking at a
different variation and realize you
overlooked something in the position and
need to check everything again that
sometimes happens but otherwise you'll
just kind of be wasting time
um the last thing I want to say is after
you have identified the threats picked
out your candidate moves gone through
some analysis for each of them the last
thing you want to do is when you've
decided on a move say we've looked at
all these moves and we decide okay H6
looks like the best move here before you
play that move this depends on what
format whether it's online or something
different but the advice my coach gave
me which applied to different situations
was actually just sit on your hands
and the reason he said that is he said
once you pick a move sit on your hands
and it will literally take you a second
to do it and it'll take you a second to
undo it to then go either click or move
the physical piece
and that will be enough time for you to
look at the position with fresh eyes
once more and say
is this a blunder am I like just giving
up a piece or missing something obvious
right so
um
this usually is like the blunder
retention or uh or blunder avoidance
check but I've played a lot of games
where I've looked and looked at a
position and analyzed a few different
moves and then finally I'm just like
okay I'm not none of these moves look
good I'm just going to play a move like
this and I just like hang upon or I hang
a piece or I give up a queen right so
just spend just it doesn't have to be
long just a few seconds at the very end
just being like okay here's the move
I've decided on
am I missing something stupid it's a
splendor so double check yourself you
will really appreciate the five seconds
you spend doing that
okay
let's move on we've spent a good deal of
time with this idea of how to think and
this is all remember this is when it's
your turn to move so we want to identify
the threats from our opponent's move
look at candidate moves analyze them
spend a little bit of time making sure
blender prevention and then play the
move
but what about when it's your opponent's
turn
um okay so when it's your opponent's
turn it's a little different so let's
look at an opening line in the Petrov
defense so uh we'll take this out of
white E4 E5 Knight to F3 and the Petrov
or the Russian defense is when black
plays Knight to F6 instead of defending
this Knight or sorry defending this Pawn
with the Knight or with a pawn
um black Is counter-attacking Us
okay the main move here is to capture
their Pawn
and black is generally advised not to
recapture right away it's a bit dubious
because there are already some dangers
of this file being so open for both
Kings right we can play a move like
Queen E2 and if you know black is not
careful if they just want to get their
Knight out of danger and do something
like Knight to F6
what can white do already to again
almost win the game on the spot
what is White's best move in this
position
okay what's your idea with Queen C4
uh that gives me the opportunity if they
make a mistake and don't catch that you
know it's obvious attack yeah you're
threatening uh Checkmate right so this
is it's kind of like a Scholars made or
like a form of Checkmate right uh it
actually
yeah I'd be I guess six moves
um but yeah so with the same weakness so
this is really good you're targeting
this weakness actually in this position
you don't even have to hope they make a
mistake they already messed up
um so that would be a decent uh try to
make an attack but we can actually
capitalize even harder because if you'll
notice our Queen and Knight are lined up
with their King so they move their
Knight out of the way which means if we
move our Knight this is a tactic called
The Discovery where our Queen will be
the one attacking their King and they
can't deal with whatever our Knight's
doing so where can we put our Knight to
do the most damage
knowing that they won't be able to deal
with it at all
we have kind of two competing thoughts
in the chat some people want to go to C6
and some people want to go to G6 and
those are the two best moves
which one do we think is better G6 or C6
and why
how come
it gives me the opportunity to capture
the coin
can they do anything to stop you from
taking the queen
correct so both moves you win something
if you play Knight to G6 we are going to
win The Rook because they're going to
have to do something to block this check
and we'll take the Rook but if we
instead play Knight to C6 we're actually
going to win the queen and even though
they can move the queen to block our
Knight on C6 still covers this Square
so in the other example they could block
with like the bishop for instance and
their Queen is still safe
um so okay this is a bit of an aside
but I just want you to have some
understanding of this defense so we know
what's going on so in this position
instead of taking our pawn and creating
some potential weaknesses
black is usually advised the first play
the move D6 and kick our Knight away
let me move our Knight now they can take
because now there's a little more safety
and there's a few different moves that
we can play here but the move I like to
play is actually Knight to C3
so if you don't have some opening
knowledge that's actually perfect for
this example if you are familiar with
this opening then that's okay I think
this will still be helpful for you
imagine we get to this point and our
opponent has been kind of blitzing out
their moves they just know already what
they're going to play and they see you
play Knight C3 and they stop and now
they need to think
and they kind of immediately are like
wait a minute
if you if I if I take this Knight you're
letting me just take this Knight you're
gonna have to double your Pawn somewhere
and double pawns are usually bad right
so they stop and think for a second and
then they're like wait well this just
must be bad so they capture your knight
and you recapture
and now they stop to think because this
is a position your opponent just hasn't
seen before so they need to think okay
what do I want to do
which means this is a position that we
get to stop and think about
how should we maximize our calculation
time while it's our opponent's turn
we have the benefit that our clock is
not ticking down right again if you're
playing in a tournament or if you're
playing casually you have the benefit
that it's not the pressure of you're
taking too long to play
um but either way
regardless just because we have that
benefit does not mean we should just be
sitting around twiddling our thumbs
until our opponent makes a move we
should be spending our time thinking
but I do think we need to go about it
differently
because if we start looking at
variations right remember before in uh
this position
we were really thinking very concretely
about okay they've made a threat we need
or sorry if the threat is this one we
need to stop it and we've looked at some
candidate moves we identified those
ideas and kind of debated did some
analysis and then made a decision
in this position it's way different
because now if we start to try and
analyze candidate moves and like
um
the continuing variations
well where do we even start because they
could play a whole bunch of moves and
really any of them are potential if you
try and analyze all of these
possibilities it's like you're going to
be sitting there again forever and we
don't have that luxury
and it's also not going to be helpful
right if you spend let's say you spend
10 minutes and you go over okay if they
play this I know exactly what I'm going
to do and then they played Bishop B7
or vice versa it's just not a good use
of time
so my advice is on your turn you want to
go through the steps I said candidate
moves calculation identifying threats
blunder prevention
I mean we'll do blender prevention here
too
but
we're going to think about it
differently
on your opponent's turn my advice is to
think really about the big picture so
look at the abstracts in the position
unless the position you're playing in is
incredibly sharp which a sharp position
is one where there's a lot of threats a
lot of things are hanging there's maybe
each side probably only has one good
move and you have to be really careful
to find it that's more tactical in those
positions you can think about the
concrete lines because you have to know
exactly the precise moves in a position
like this like maybe some moves are plus
0.1 better
but that doesn't really mean anything an
opponent can reasonably play any of
these moves and we're going to have to
be prepared for all of them
um so we should think big picture
um
some of the questions I like to ask are
where do I want my king to be
do I want it to stay in the center
throwing it to Castle kingside don't
Castle Queen side
let me ask you for this position what do
you think where do you want your king to
be
I know it's Black's turn to move so
they're going to be the one moving but
eventually do we want this King to be
over on the king side over on the queen
side or
somewhere in the middle or maybe we're
undecided
what do you all feel what would you
where would you want your king
okay you want King side
I see a few people saying kingside in
the chat
I mean we definitely don't want it in
the center because we've just moved our
Center Pawn out of the way this one's
gone which means if we keep it here it's
just a Sitting Duck so we do need to get
it out of the way
um most people are saying kingside I
think the argument for the king side is
it's faster we don't want our King to be
in the center for long and if you just
do something like you know Bishop just
move this bishop anywhere really and
then Castle our King is safe and I think
that's very true
when I look at this position I actually
agree with Teo in the chat I want a
castle queenside I think they're both
possible
but I'm anticipating my opponent
actually wants to kingside Castle
because they have three pieces in the
way of queenside castling their King is
also fairly exposed in the center so
they're thinking the same thing we are
right they want to get their King safe
but now look at this how on Earth is
black going to attack our King for the
next two or three moves
I think we have enough time to safely
queenside Castle even though it's not
quite as fast I still think we can do it
so if we are able to then we get two
benefits one
we get the benefit of this extra Pawn
that acts as a shield that's going to
try and intercept if they start pushing
pawns against us we have an extra Pawn
we just put here that's going to block
our path
secondly if we coincide castle and our
opponent kingside castles well now we
have our own series of Pawns that we're
free to launch for an attack very
quickly
um and it's harder for them to do that
as we said because we've got this
blocker
so I want a castle Queen side here
but okay that's one question where
should we put our King another question
is related here where should I push my
pawns sometimes in the center sometimes
on the queen side in this case my
argument is let's Castle Queen side push
him on the king side
you can ask questions like what do I
think is the best Square for my
undeveloped pieces you know where does
this bishop want to go
where does this queen want to go and if
you can start to answer those questions
then you can start to think okay well
maybe I want my queen to go to E2 and
call check and attack this file
but I don't want to do that before this
bishop moves so maybe I need to move
this bishop somewhere first where do I
want to put it
and you can kind of go down the line and
start asking questions like this and
it's going to help you think whenever
your opponent makes a move whatever move
that happens to be you are now in a much
better position to do the process we
said before are there any threats what
are our candidate moves well now we have
a whole bunch because we know exactly
what we want out of this position
same thing like if they play Move Like
Bishop G4 we can ask these questions
what are the threats okay there's a pin
so I don't really want to deal with that
I can start looking at if there's other
threats can they attack this pinned
piece it'll probably take a little too
long but maybe in a few moves so maybe I
break out of the pin maybe I attack the
bishop and we can go through this line
again
um
but but I want to still emphasize on
when it's our opponent's turn
so ask yourselves big picture questions
about the position where do you want
your king
which side are we fighting on
where should the pieces be ideally
placed do you notice that this is a
tactical position or is it relatively
kind of just dry and positional
is the position open or closed right if
stuff is very locked up
then you're going to play differently
versus if it's really not maybe you're
behind in the position and you're
looking to play for a draw trying to
find stalemate tricks
um you'll play differently in different
phases of the game right if it's the
opening maybe I don't want to get my
queen out too early but if it's the
end game maybe I need to get my king
into the game and be a fighting piece so
again I'm giving this all to you as kind
of abstract thoughts but my advice is to
really think when it's your opponent's
turn spend less time unless you're in a
very sharp position spend less time on
concrete variations and more time trying
to understand the position make
long-term plans because then when it
comes to your turn you're going to be in
a much better position to actually
evaluate your candidate moves
okay I've done enough lecturing let's
look at some more positions
in this position it is white to move and
white plays to move Bishop takes C4
so it is now our turn
what should we think about here
given all the steps I just gave first
step we want to identify well first we
want to note what their moves okay they
played Bishop C4 our Pawn is not there
their Bishop is there
are there any threats in this position
what do we think what threats
have they made
either with that specific move or that
are now maybe more dangerous because of
that move
which one I'm sorry okay so threading on
E6 so
um do you think this is a credible
threat
like is this something they're probably
gonna do
no
yeah why not
yeah
so this is pretty defended and then
usually you don't want to trade a bishop
for a pawn right a bishop will say it's
worth about three points a pawn is worth
about one so usually they wouldn't want
to take here
um so the the place The Bishop's at
doesn't look like it's actually making
any immediate threats which is good for
us
and there's no like discoveries it
wasn't blocking anything I mean their
King is ready to Castle now so they have
some positional ideas but I don't see
any immediate threats
okay A lot of people are now taking a
look now at uh what are some candidate
moves and let me ask you two uh do you
have any candidate moves stuff that
jumps out to you in this position you
might want to look at playing
we have a lot of people in the chat
suggesting one move
the bishop to A4 uh or to B4 here
or this one to A4 yeah
the sorry which one A4 or okay so a
bishop to A4 what's your idea
yeah so we are hitting the queen and the
queen needs to do something about it
there is a bit of a downside right
um the problem is do we have anything
that's defending our A4 Square
like that's going to help support our
Bishop attack the queen
so unfortunately if we play Bishop A4
immediately then the queen will just be
able to take it
so it's not a bad idea yeah no no
worries it's not a bad idea
um but we do want to we'll have to set
that up so we might need
um that could be a more long-term thing
to be aware of like I'm imagining if we
are able to Castle like get this bishop
out of the White Castle and maybe put
our Bishop or sorry our Queen on E8 to
work with the bishop that could be one
method you could try and like trade
these pawns and then activate your Rook
to defend
so that could be a nice long-term plan
but not for me it's not an immediate
candidate move
other ideas in this position
yeah so Bishop to B4 here and the idea
is
well actually it's doing two things one
this just is a free Pawn looks like
right there's nothing defending it and
we're going to pin this uh Pawn to the
king so they won't be able to push in
the center I mean they can get out of
that pretty quickly by castling but
we're still picking up a pawn and
putting them in a threatening position
so okay before we come into a move right
we want to identify some like generally
most of our candidate moves but if you
can quickly take a look and say okay
maybe I play Knight C6 maybe like just
bring the bishop out here
you're going to be hard-pressed to find
okay is there a like why would I not
just take a free Pawn
um now this is kind of a tricky position
because you do want to I don't want to
get too deep in the Weeds on this one in
particular but white does have some
interesting counter attacks if we play
Bishop before we do before we play this
move want to consider what they could do
in response to us so again more concrete
thinking
um
and in this case they actually have a
really tricky move Queen to B3
which would attack our Bishop and if we
move our Bishop it would attack our Pawn
here on B7
now this is not an Unstoppable problem
we can actually get out of this
uh
but we have to be a little careful about
it but
um
yeah again I don't want to get too far
down on this one but the idea is if we
want to make it so that Queen taking
because we we don't have a move that's
going to defend both
um if we just move the bishop away
then they're going to take here and our
Rook is going to be in danger and at the
very least they've won this Pawn back
maybe we're doing better because our
development is better
um if we try and defend our Bishop
then they can play something like Pawn
to A3 and again the same thing happens
our Bishop is forced to leave and they
will take this Pawn we actually have a
very nice trick that it looks like who
saw in the chat has found and maybe a
few other people where if we play Knight
C6
and they uh they can't take the bishop
they can attack it and after we retreat
they now can't take this because if they
do
what is the punishing move we can play
against them what is the problem with
Queen takes Pawn in this variation
black to move
yeah a few people will chat have some
good ideas so one person suggested uh or
maybe a few people suggested Knight A5
net A5 looks very strong forking the
queen and the bishop
the problem is white can actually defend
both if they play Queen to A6 their
Queen is safe and they defend their
Bishop
however
we have an even better move Rook to B8
our Knight actually really cleanly
defends our rook and pawn so all of this
stuff is safe
the queen still has to get out of the
way
and now Rook takes B2 and we win this
bishop so that's a little aside not the
main point of this lecture but
regardless the kind of thing you would
want to be thinking about in this
position right if it's our turn to move
then we see okay we have a really
obvious candidate move Bishop takes B4
we can consider a few others but seeing
as this looks so appealing this would be
a circumstance where I'd say okay it's
okay so let's analyze this a little
deeper because if we can't find a good
reason not to do it like you don't want
to give your opponent the benefit of the
doubt
um that they have something there that
you don't see because if you play like
that then you're giving them the
advantage without even having them have
to work for it so you do want to spend
some time in calculate but you don't
want to they could be bluffing you know
you want to call their Bluffs
okay
let's jump to another position once
again in this position
it is uh black to move and black plays
the move Queen to E6 it is now our turn
again so let's go through our process
first question
they play the new Queen E6 what are the
threats do they have any threats in the
position with that move or just in
general
what do you see
what should we be concerned about here
and while you're thinking so yeah twm um
yeah so the basic idea we're going to
look at the bishop B4 move
um and just calculate it
this is the kind of thing you'll go a
little bit down the variation tree I
imagine it like a literal tree right you
have the main ideas as the trunk right I
think I'm going to play Bishop B4 and
then I think they're going to play Queen
B3 and then I think I'm going to play 96
and whatever you think and then you can
do little branches as variations
um that's the part where you know the
better a player you are the more you can
calculate the farther you can go but
even if you're you know just starting
out you can still spend you know a
minute or two looking okay if they play
this I think I'm gonna do this or if
they play this I think I'm going to do
this and just start to be a little bit
prepared for it
okay so does anyone see any threats in
this position
anything you're worried about from black
here
um
sure so maybe we'd have to be a little
careful with Queen to B3 they are pretty
close to our King the downside and
actually think remember they came from e
or sorry from C4
so they could have played this here and
decided not to so maybe they're a little
nervous about getting their Queen too
far in enemy territory it doesn't have a
lot of backup right now but I can see
why that might be a bit of a concern
to me the main concern I have is I don't
want them to push this Pawn forward and
try and break into my position
so I I kind of want to stop that but
that's the only real threat I'm worried
about so after we say there's not really
any major threats except maybe them
pushing this Pawn
the next thing you want to do is
identify our candidate moves so
spend a minute in bullet and get [ __ ]
well bullet is a whole different Beast
calculation is a little harder there
um
okay so what are some of our candidate
moves what moves look reasonable to you
all here for white
and let's just name a few of them
okay Rook C1 suggested
what else
Knight D5
suggested
uh Bishop takes F6
I think you could make an argument for
Bishop H6
as a candidate move
H4 suggested
so a lot of different moves so far and
what we would do is then in this
position we would spend some time
analyzing what do we think is the best
of those
so
um let's imagine so I play the piercing
King's Indian defense a lot so I'm used
to this position and I see this bishop
H6 idea as a very common theme trying to
trade off these Bishops so let's imagine
I think that looks like probably the
best move
I'm going to play this move or not play
it but I will imagine it in my head and
think okay well obviously they shouldn't
take because then my queen gets into
their territory
and the reason I would usually want to
do this is because then I'm going to
remove their bishop and their King will
be a little weaker
this might be an okay long-term strategy
um but in the short term I don't think
I'm going to be able to attack too much
so I'll keep that on the back burner and
then I'll look at another move and
actually a lot of people in chat have
found really unusually in this position
we actually want to give up our Bishop
not for this bishop normally we want to
weaken these Pawns
um and to kind of clarify what that
means if I just play some silly looking
move here
notice how in this position these pawns
all cover the light squares
and the bishop is no longer there to
cover all of these dark squares so this
is a weakness that we can potentially
try and exploit in the long term
so that's why I'm considering this idea
of Bishop H6 but actually Bishop takes
F6 makes a lot of sense here because
whether they take back with the queen or
the bishop
let's say they take with the queen then
we can activate our Knight on this
really monstrous Square D5 where it
attacks everything it is like a octopus
or a kraken it's horrifying and this
bishop just can't compare
this bishop cannot ever interact with it
because it's on a dark Square
um I don't know that it's necessary
first but I like it first just to
clarify the position
so maybe you could consider some other
candidate moves that um
are doing something different the fact
that this Knight is pinned means
probably we can delay this slightly but
I don't really see any good reason to
wait this looks pretty solid
so okay so again what we did is we first
saw they played their move we spent some
time saying are there any threats maybe
there's a few little ones but I don't
see anything big let's look for
candidate moves then what moves do we
want to play on the position
um
and we'll analyze them until we find
something that seems to be good or as
good as we can find
we'll sit on our hands make sure okay
does Bishop F6 blunder anything silly
doesn't look like it we'll go for it
um okay
let's look we have a little bit more
time left about five minutes so I want
to look at one more position here
in this position
it is black to move and we are up a lot
of material but black plays this move
Queen takes E3
let's go through our process
first question are there any threats in
this position
so D will see any threats that black is
making with this move Queen takes E3
that we need to be aware of
so yeah the queen can threaten to now
invade our King if it goes to G1 our
Rook actually here is able to defend
um so it is getting close to our King so
G1 is not the immediate threat but it is
good to be aware that that's a potential
check
any other threats made by this move
yeah so some people in the chat are
suggesting if they go Queen to G3 then
they can now go Queen to G2 with the
bishop and that would be Checkmate so we
have to be a little careful of that
um although that is going to be at least
two moves so maybe we would have a move
to get something in for the defense
there's actually an even bigger threat
so see if you can find if it was Black's
turn to move right now black is winning
the game even though they're down I
think two nights right we have even
Rooks even Queens
Bishop for Bishop but we still have two
knights but if it's Black's tournament
black is winning this game so we need to
really be careful about identifying the
threats the hint I will give you
is this bishop is doing more than it
seems
foreign
a few people are seeing in the chat the
right idea
so if it's Black starting to move the
problem is this bishop
is actually pinning our Pawn on G2 to
the king meaning this Pawn cannot move
because if it moves we would be in check
which means what can black do
sure exactly this Pawn is pinned so this
is not really defended so Queen takes H3
our king would have to move we can't
block to G1 and then Queen takes G2
Checkmate and that's faster right if
they play here and then here we get a
move to try and stop it but this we have
no time so now that we have identified
the threat
let's run some candidate moves what
might you consider playing here as white
to stop this threat
okay a lot of ideas coming in the chat
right now key H2 suggested Rook F3
suggested yep perfect Queen G4 suggested
Knight F3 suggested
so I'll tell you the good news about
this position is that I'm pretty sure
all of those moves are fine
um because we are up two pieces two
nights
as long as we can stop the major threat
to our King
then we're going to be okay and actually
I'm going to check with a computer real
quick yeah like every move is fine King
H2 is fine Knight F3 is fine
um basically as long as we can either
defend this Pawn right so if we play
King F2 we defend or if we block the
Queen's ability to attack it
or if we put a piece in the way of this
pin
then we're good Rook F3 actually this
bishop does take but we're still
probably up so much material that we can
get away with it
um but the way we find this is again you
stop and sit and say okay what are the
threats and if we look long enough and
can spot things carefully enough we can
actually start to see oh wait a minute
this is a problem this is a problem
and then you can come up with your list
of candidate moves what do you think is
going to be good you can go through them
and find if you find any of them that
give you an advantage feel free to stop
there and play it after you do some
blunder prevention by sitting on your
hands but you can also spend a little
time depending on how much time you have
looking at other ideas and seeing if
there's anything that's even better
there's a famous Tres Axiom that if you
see a good move look for a better one
and I think that is true in a lot of
situations except when you're you know
down on time or something like that so
something good to consider for you as
well
okay hopefully this has been informative
to give you the recap
when you are thinking about moves to
make you want to do two things when it's
your turn you want to be very concrete
and think okay first what are the
threats second what are my candidate
moves if there are threats what moves
can I play to stop them or nullify them
and if there are no threats then how can
I make my own threats or develop or
whatever goals I'm trying to achieve in
the position
once you've identified your candidate
moves you'll analyze them each and try
and find which one gives you the biggest
Advantage comparing them to each other
when you've made your final selection
set on your hands give it a final check
over make sure you're not missing
anything silly and then play the move if
it's your opponent's turn you want to
think more abstractly big picture what
are my long-term goals in this position
where do I want my king to be where do I
want my pieces to be am I attacking on
the king side of the queen side is this
should I trade for a winning end game
you have time to think about these big
questions because your opponent's the
one who's going to have to look at all
the different variations
so that's my advice to you I hope it's
been helpful and please stick around our
next class will be given by Grandmaster
Igor novikov uh right after this
probably just in a few minutes so please
stick around for that thank you as
always for joining and I look forward to
seeing you again soon
[Music]